[Applause]
[Music]
america's got talent contestant nolan
neal has died he was 41.
according to tmz the musician who also
competed on the voice was found dead in
his apartment in nashville tennessee
[Music]
[Music]
authorities at the metropolitan
nashville police department say they got
a call from nolan's roommate who found
him unconscious in his bedroom at night
police say the roommate checked on nolan
after receiving a call from the singer's
mom who was concerned when she hadn't
heard from him
right now the musician's cause of death
is still unknown e.t has reached out to
nolan's reps for comment
[Music]
the late singer was known for his
powerhouse vocals on season 10 of the
voice where he joined adam levine's team
you're going to be the first guy
who went home last season and who won
this season
you belong right here during his run on
the show in 2016 he made it to the
knockout round before being eliminated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in an interview with the tv station in
knoxville tennessee nolan revealed he
battled addiction during his time on the
voice i got clean
in 2010 may 15th i went to rehab
and i stayed clean for three years and
then
i joined a rough band hinder
and you know their lyrics and everything
was all about drinking and partying
i was just lying to myself telling
myself that i could control it
nolan made his big return to the stage
on agt in 2020 and nailed his audition
singing an original song he wrote
talking about his substance abuse
struggles
tonight it's a song called lost that i
wrote right out of treatment it's the
first song i wrote sober
[Music]
police reportedly claim a guitar pick
was found next to the singer's bed and
appeared to contain a powder residue
after his time on the talent
competitions nolan continued to release
his music on tick tock full of lyrics
that talked about overcoming pain
we're sending our thoughts and prayers
to all who love nolan
i can't take anymore trying to pretend
you don't ever do lie
cause i know
when you go
[Music]
you